[موسيقى]
تتصاعد الشكوك اليوم حول ماذا يقوم الى
الماسك الان بالذات ما انتخابات التجديد
النصفي في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي بطرد نحو
نصف الموظفين العديد منهم يعملون في مجال
مراقبه المحتوى يتحدث بان ذلك يحصل بحسب
تراجع اعلانات المعلمين حيث اليوم تخسر
تويتر اربعه ملايين دولار يوميا من هذه
الاعلانات بسبب ضغوطات المجتمعات
الانسانيه على المعلمين التي تطلب منهم
ايقاف اعلاناتهم على المنصه ايضا علامات
التحقق الزرقاء لم تعد حكرا على المشاهير
فقط اليوم اي شخص يمكنها الحصول عليها
مقابل ثمان دولارات لو كان عندهم او لو
كان عنده مليون ايضا هناك شيء اخر يريد
ماسك اضافته الى تويتر او اعادته الى
تويتر او الفيديوهات القصيره التي كانت
سابقا تشبه تلك التي موجوده على التيك توك
ولكن قاموا بايقافها اليوم يريد اعاده هذه
فيديوهات ويسال كيف لنا ان نجعلها افضل
[موسيقى]